Ich überspringe das Ende der
Befragung von Zombies bei einem Erdbeben. Ein
anderes Telefon ist ein absoluter roter
Stern, der klar ist. Backstreet Boys. Dies sind
Nima-Tiere, da Nakatta McInturff einen
islamischen Quickie-Design-Martin darstellt. Es war
kein Muhammad und eine
Pressekonferenz auf Taaha-Pitch  im tandem
von zeichen 880 unterstrich botschafter
unbesiegbar und eigenmarke sang es
hoffe design auflösung auflösung auf
krawatte name ist stand wichtig hallo geht es
dir gut und wie geht es dir
fantastisch perfekt wirklich gut baby also
ja bis jetzt okay ich habe jedes
mal  Die erste Frage ist die gleiche wie
bei Click Boom. Wie läuft es?
Alles ist großartig. Ich bin aufgeregt. Ich freue mich,
dass es veröffentlicht wird. Ausverkauft. Ja, endlich die
Chance bekommen, Musik zu
schreiben  Um mich von der Person zu distanzieren
, die das erste Album irgendwie gemalt hat, also
habe
ich viel gelernt, habe viele
Plattentouren mit den Jungs gemacht, viel gelernt, also bist du
heute eine andere Person als  Die Zeit,
ja ja, das ist anders, ich
denke, talentmäßig, ein besserer Klang, ich fühle mich
körperlich viel stärker, ich
bin stärker in der Lage, die Arbeit zu ertragen, die
ein Solokünstler erfordert, dann bin ich auch
nur. Ich bin nur  Ich bin ein besserer Autor und
auch ein besserer Songwriter
, um so früh anzufangen und Karriere zu machen, es ist ein bisschen
wie ein Spaziergang durch die Hölle, du weißt,
es geht so schnell vorbei, du weißt nicht wirklich,
du weißt, es ist, als würdest du ein Tattoo bekommen
und einmal  Der Schmerz ist vorbei, deshalb
tue ich weiterhin, was ich tue, um herauszufinden, dass a
um diesen Nervenkitzel zu bekommen, den Sie kennen, um diesen
Erfolg zu erzielen, wissen Sie, dass dies das ist, was jeder
Künstler getan hat oder versucht hat, diese Übung zu bekommen,
und darum geht es hier nicht
dein Privatleben ist ein bisschen kurz
davor, du musst weniger
Privatleben machen. Ich weiß nicht, du weißt, dass man es so sehen kann
, aber ich meine, ich bin ein
Entertainer, also mag ich es einfach, dass ich mich entschieden habe,
also
lebe ich  und ich liebe es, also hast du mir erzählt, dass du
technisch gesehen ein Tattoo hast,
aber bevor es anders war,
höre ich  d Ich weiß nicht, dass du redest,
hahaha, okay, das ist der Punkt, über den du nicht
gerne sprichst, es liegt in der Vergangenheit, du
weißt, wie ich schon sagte, das Tattoo, der Schmerz ist
weg, der Schmerz, den du durchgemacht hast, ist
vorbei, aber der  Pass ist auch ein Teil Ihrer
Persönlichkeit, definitiv ein Teil der
Persönlichkeit, aber ich denke
, der Zukunft mehr Aufmerksamkeit zu schenken als der Vergangenheit, das macht Sie irgendwie
zu Lawsons und verwandelt Sie in
eine einzigartigere Person. Ich denke, das ist es, was
ich ihm gesagt habe
gesund sein glücklicher sein talentierter sein
mich selbst herauszufordern Richtungen aber was du
aus all der Zeit gelernt
hast, ist die Hauptsache, die Hauptsache, die ich
gelernt habe, ist, dass wir es nicht
ändern können  könnte
ich mich genauso gut auf die Zukunft freuen und das würde
mich irgendwie in eine andere
Position bringen, eine andere Denkweise, die
ich zu meinem Vorteil nutzen könnte,
wenn es um eine
erfolgreiche Karriere ging, wissen Sie, ich meine, das ist es
, was  ich habe gelernt ich habe gelernt
th  Dabei gibt es so viel mehr zu lassen
, okay mit einem guten Punkt, aber
die Hauptsache ist eine Karriere für dich auf diese
Weise. Ja, ich bin erst 31 Jahre alt, also da
draußen habe ich das Gefühl, dass es kein Problem gibt,
okay, vielen Dank  aber das war
nur der anfang okay